Well, good morning, faith family. It is a joy, man,
I tell you. Uh, it is really good to be back together again.
Uh, if you're new to our church, you might be wondering what's even going on,
like who this new guy is. Uh, I've been on sabbatical for the last three months.
My name's John Wolgemuth. I'm one of the pastors here. Uh, it has been a,
a good time.
I'll share more about that next Sunday about like kind of all of what happened
with the time of rest and what God taught me and showed me and challenged me
with. Uh, there were some, some really sweet times. We got to focus together.
My wife and I on each other got to focus on our time with our sons.
We got to travel a little bit. We got to do a lot of memory making things.
Just have a great time together and spend a load of time together, uh,
that we don't take for granted.
There are also some unique challenges in my soul, uh, that I did not anticipate.
And so, uh, I get to share more about that, uh, more deeply next Sunday.
But I do want to just start by saying a massive thank you to you as a church,
uh, just for the time away. Uh, that,
that we feel so loved and supported and cared for,
that this is part of our policies as a church,
that every five years this gets to happen for my position,
for others on our staff. Uh, we get those every five years. Just that's,
that's something we care about one another so deeply and you support and love us
so well. We don't take that for granted. Uh,
that's a huge blessing for us to get to do that. So thank you. Uh,
what a blessing it is for that,
but also what a blessing it is to know that that like, you know, we,
we saw the Lord continue to work right through his word.
It was not that we left and everything shut down for three months.
It was God worked.
And so what a blessing it is to know how many faithful proclaimers of God's word
we have around here. It's just a gift to see that we have so many.
It's also a blessing, uh,
how much our staff and volunteers just continued on.
And we see that in fact,
things have grown and done well in the last three months.
What a blessing that is to me and to know that this is awesome,
to watch God work through his people. Now,
as you've already heard already today is what we are designating as Missions
Sunday. Really, if you've been around here at any length of time, you know,
pretty much every Sunday's mission Sunday, you know, and you are sent,
like that's who we are.
But with Perry coming on board and now some new opportunities we're seeing over
the next few weeks and months, we wanted to, to highlight that. Plus,
I've gotten asked a few times over the last week plus like, did I,
did I get any new vision or, or fresh word from the Lord on the time away?
Like is it,
is that's happened in the past before People go and they come back with
something different. It's like, did that happen? Well,
I'd have to answer that with a big fat no. Uh,
really there's nothing different about the direction that God is taking us.
We believe that that's been something he's affirmed over the last couple years.
We see we're gonna talk about it again today.
That direction and goal hasn't changed, but I,
I did sense some caution and I'll share a little bit at the end of the sermon
today about that. And so we'll get to that.
Once I walk through our mission again next week,
I'm gonna share about my sabbatical, what true rest really looks like,
which I think will be instructive for us as a church, as individuals.
Then the next week will be a,
a sermon on serving as we head into the fall before then August 13th,
promotion Sunday.
We're gonna begin just a slow walk through the Book of Colossians,
just verse by verse through the entire book for the fall.
So you can look ahead to that.
But today we need to recall our mission that aligns everything
we do as a church, from kids all the way up to senior adults.
What aligns us as a church, what do we do?
We're gonna recall our mission as a church today.
And so we'll start by turning together in God's word to Paul's letter
to the Ephesians. You can grab your copy God's word, turn to the New Testament.
We're gonna jump around a little bit from there. Uh, jump around a little bit,
but we'll start in New Testament in Ephesians chapter four,
Ephesians four. Now, I kind of briefly mentioned it,
but what do we mean when we talk about mission?
Talk about our mission as a church. What does that even mean?
And so here's another way to put it. When you think about the mission,
mission statement, whatever you wanna call it,
another way to put it is what has God called our church uniquely to do
that will shape us into disciple makers who go both locally and
globally?
What should drive our daily tasks?
Why we do what we do as a church? Why do we do that?
That's really a good summary of our mission. In fact,
God has inspired the book of Ephesians as a pretty good model for,
for a proper life orientation, ideal life orientation.
The Ephesians is a good way to go about looking at that cuz the first
three chapters of Ephesians highlights the glory of God in his nature.
Just who he is, what he's done in his, his self,
but then also how he saves sinners like you and me, how he builds his church.
It's all the first three chapters about how God works in the world himself,
who he is.
It records phrases over and over like to the praise of his glorious grace,
the father of glory. It says Jesus is far above all.
And then the way chapter three ends, it says to him,
be glory throughout all generations, forever and ever.
Like so that's the way the whole book starts. It says highlights.
This is who he is. Remember who he is. Don't forget who he is.
And so everything we do is under that umbrella.
Everything we do as a a church, everything we do as individuals,
it's all preeminently for his glory.
It's the way he designed it and he deserves it.
But then what chapters four through six do is they show us the
practical outworking of that nature of God,
of his glorious salvation in us, of his building, of his church. He,
he shows us, Paul shows us in the inspiration of the Holy Spirit.
This is the way it should look when you go about your daily life.
That God's work in us changes us. It changes how we speak,
it changes how we sing. It changes how we give. It changes how we parent.
It changes how we work.
It even changes how we walk together in unity as a faith family.
The gospel, God's glory in salvation changes everything.
That's the context here as we get into Ephesians chapter four,
he's talking about that church setting verses 11 through
16. Look at it with me now. That's big number four in Ephesians.
Down under that, under that is little number 11.
He gave the apostles, this is Jesus. He gave the apostles, the prophets,
the evangelists,
the shepherds and teachers to equip the saints for the work of ministry,
for building up the body of Christ until we all attain to the unity of
the faith and of the knowledge of the Son of God to mature manhood to the
measure of the stature of the fullness of Christ.
So that we may no longer be children tossed to and fro by the waves and carried
about by every wind of doctrine, by human cunning,
by craftiness and deceitful schemes.
Rather speaking the truth and love.
We are to grow up in every way into him who is the head into Christ,
from whom the whole body joined and held together by every joint with which it
is equipped. When each part is working properly,
it makes the body grow so that it builds itself up in love.
And so here you see why our mission statement begins with this phrase,
equipping one another. It's right here, right?
Equipping one another. What this verse is,
has said is that we are to make sure that each one of us is ready for God's
work.
And did you see how important it is for every one of us to be equipped and to be
utilizing the gifts that God has given us? You, you saw how important it is,
right? So that the entire church is built up, is unified,
is growing into Christ likeness.
That's how important this is. What that means is that you,
if you have repented and believed in Jesus, in your place,
if you are a Christian,
God did not save you to sit on the sidelines that you
are called into his mission, into his ministry.
That means I need you. That means you need me.
That means you need each other.
That means every single one of us Christians,
every single one of us are mission critical.
We'll talk more about that in two weeks. But, but this is how important it is
without one another.
We don't build up into the stature of Christ.
Now that starts in just attending.
You can't build one up if you're never with one another. And I,
I say that because I can't express to you how special that is to be back
together, how much I needed this, how much I needed my faith.
Family was never meant to do this by ourselves.
Now of course, it's nice to travel a little bit.
It was sweet to be visiting churches that my friends pastor locally or,
or even a little bit further away or,
or churches that we used to serve at before we go visit them and see family and
and friends there. But, but the way I compare it to,
and this is the only way I could think about how it felt was,
was like when you go visit extended family, you know,
like at Thanksgiving or Christmas or other events and you go see people like
cousins and, and extended out family that that, that you know,
you're connected to and, and you're in relationship with,
you know you love each other,
but you don't really have that same depth of relationship that you do with your
immediate family, right? You, you know, you're connected,
you know, you family, you know, you would sacrifice for each other,
but it's not the same as home, right?
And so Emily and I were talking about that even just last Sunday as we visited
friends down in Newcastle and, and it was great.
God's work is being done. We're proclaiming the gospel.
We're thankful for what he's doing through them. And, and, and we're in,
in full support of that. But we're sitting there thinking like,
this is not home to us.
Excited to get back here this week. Of course this is how much I needed this.
We need this.
That's why it was so sweet that I didn't jump right into just being here at the,
the offices and study all week. I jumped right into student camp this week.
Like so I was there with our students.
It was so sweet though because I got to,
to experience their joy in the gospel and be filled up by their passion
to participate in some coincidence with them and to be excited about all kinds
of things that we nobody, no nothing, nothing. No. Okay.
Um, but just to,
to to hear them passionately sing to the glory of God.
Man, it was so refreshing cuz I know them, I love them.
And then we're singing Together's a family, it was awesome.
And then to be back here with you today is so needed.
So when we talk about being the body of Christ together,
this is not just a bunch of disconnected parts.
This is a body meant to be together.
So don't don't miss out on that. Don't put it as a low priority.
So showing up is part of it. But you saw an Ephesians four,
there's so much more to it, right?
Getting into deep relationships with people and we do that through d groups and
community groups and Wednesday nights and,
and being equipped for God's work serving one another.
There's all kinds of things we'll see in a couple weeks, even d
equipped for God's work. But the question is,
what are we equipping each other for? Okay, equipped for God's work.
But what is it? What is it that we're equipping each other for?
Well first we have said it this way,
that it's equipping one another to love Jesus.
First and foremost, we're equipping one another to love Jesus.
Now, yes, we believe that God is three in one trinity, father,
son Holy Spirit. And Jesus said in Matthew 22,
you are to love the Lord your God with all your heart, soul, and mind.
What we're doing in our statement by saying to love Jesus is we're clarifying
what our culture generically refers to as some kind of God but
doesn't know anything about him.
Because the God we worship is not just the man upstairs,
it's not just somebody out there, uh, a clockmaker setting it all in order. No,
we worship Yahweh,
the God who created everything,
yet the God who also became flesh and dwelt among us.
That's how we can know him. And that's,
that's radically different than every other religious system out there,
is that the God is not out there needing us to appease him. God came to us
this Yahweh who created everything. And that's,
that's great and we talk about that and we encourage one another with that.
But the reason we can love Yahweh,
we can love Jesus with all that we are is because of what we find in Luke
chapter seven.
So we're gonna turn left from where we were in Ephesians four or scroll up on
your device to the gospel according to Luke chapter
seven,
why can we say love Jesus in our mission?
Luke seven will start in verse 36.
And here's what we're gonna find. We're gonna find a pr,
a prideful religious leader looking down on a woman who's known as a
sinner. He's looking down culturally and spiritually at this sinful woman,
but we're also gonna see her response to Jesus.
And then we'll see Jesus' response to her and by implication to
this religious leader as well. But this is a powerful section.
Look at verses 36 through 50. Luke seven,
one of the Pharisees asked Jesus to eat with him and he went into the Pharisees
house and reclined at the table and behold a woman of the city
who was a sinner.
When she learned that Jesus was reclining at table in the Pharisees house,
she brought an alabaster flask, ointment.
So it would've been worth a lot of money.
And standing behind him at his feet weeping,
she began to wet his feet with her tears and wipe them with the hair of her head
and kissed his feet and anointed them with the ointment.
And when the Pharisee who invited him saw this, he said to himself,
if this man were a prophet,
he would've known who and what sort of woman this is,
who is touching him for she's a sinner.
And Jesus answering. Remember that guy said that in his own mind,
Jesus answering said to him, Simon, I have something to say to you.
And he answered, say it teacher. And Jesus gives this parable. Verse 41,
A certain money lender had two debtors, one owed 500 denar I,
which is an incredibly large sum of money.
And the other 50 when they could not pay,
he canceled the debt of both. Now which of them will love him more?
And Simon answered logically the one I suppose for whom he canceled the larger
debt. Jesus said to him, you've judged rightly
then turning toward the woman, he said to Simon, did you, do you see this woman?
I entered your house, you gave me no water for my feet,
but she has wet my feet with her tears and wiped them with her hair.
You gave me no kiss. But from the time I came in,
she has not ceased to kiss my feet.
You did not anoint my head with oil, but she's anointed my feet with ointment.
Therefore I tell you her sins, which are many are forgiven for she loved much,
but he who is forgiven little loves little.
And he said to her, your sins are forgiven.
And those were who were at the table with them began to say among themselves,
who is this? Who even forgives sins?
And he said to the woman, your faith has saved you.
Go in peace. Is that not stunning?
You can just picture in your head, right,
how beautiful that scene would've been for her. How,
how confrontational that scene would've been for Simon.
And listen, you might have walked in here
feeling just like that woman.
You might feel cast off from society.
You might feel too dirty, you've messed up too much, you're unlovable.
But see the extravagance of God's love in Jesus here,
like it's his love is not for those who pretend like they have it all together.
His love is for those who know they don't have it all together,
who know they're desperate without Jesus.
That's where his love flows out too.
And understanding that leads to you to respond like she did.
Like when you remember how far from God you are on your own,
yet he saved you. That's when it overflows out of your heart.
That's when it overflows out of your mouth and you sing.
That's when it overflows out of your life to serve.
That's when it overflows out of your pocketbook,
out of your eyes when you're tearing up because you can't help but be grateful
for his salvation.
That's where it starts to come out of you is when you remember how far
from him you are on your own.
And yet he reached through the sin and said,
you're mine. Listen,
if Jesus is just a transaction to you,
like if he's just an add-on to your life so that you look better with your
friends or you look better at work,
if that's all that he is, then of course you won't be passionate about him.
Of course you won't love him because he's just a little piece of your life.
But if Jesus is your very life,
if he is everything to you, if he's your only hope,
if he's the rock on which you build everything,
if you know he's redeemed you from all your sin,
that's when love abounds for Jesus.
It's bad news makes the good news that much sweeter. This
woman knew who she was. She knew what she'd done.
She knew what everybody had called her,
but she also knew who Jesus was.
That's why she responded the way that she did.
Don't miss it. Church. She is every one of us,
every one of us, we're all far from God on our own,
we're all dirty, we're all messed up. But when we come to him for forgiveness,
that's when we can love.
And so we are called to equip one another to love Jesus. But,
but that's not the only thing he's called us to.
Because what can happen is if we just focus on that,
we just focus on our inner relationship with the Lord.
That's when we begin to get really self-centered and self-focused and inward
focused. We are also commanded all of our scripture to love others as ourselves,
to make disciples who make more disciples.
We're we're commanded by the Lord to do these things
as well as to love Jesus. And so we're, the way we summarize it around here,
you've heard it already today, is to live sent.
We are equipping one another to love Jesus and to live sent,
that's also part of what he's called us to.
We're gonna see this over in Second Corinthians chapter five.
So you're gonna turn right now, not all the way to Ephesians,
but you're gonna go to second Corinthians,
another letter from Paul second Corinthians five verses 14 through 21.
We're gonna see this idea of living sent in second Corinthians five
14 through 21.
He's talking a lot about the future, our heavenly dwelling.
But what he's now doing in this little section is he's going to show us
how that fleshes out into, as we wait,
as we're getting ready for the wedding supper of the lamb, like we sang earlier,
verse 14,
for the love of Christ controls us because we have concluded this.
That one has died for all. Therefore all have died. He died for all that.
Those who live might no longer live for themselves,
but for him who for their sake died and was raised from now on.
Therefore, we regard no one according to the flesh.
Even though we once regarded Christ according to the flesh, we regard him,
thus no longer meaning he's, he's not in the physical form like he was before.
Therefore, if anyone is in Christ, he is a new creation.
Be old, has passed away.
Behold the newest come and all this is from God who through Christ reconciled us
to himself and gave us the ministry of reconciliation
that is in Christ. God was reconciling the world to himself,
not counting their trespasses against them and entrusting to us the
message of reconciliation. Therefore, because he's given all this,
we are ambassadors for Christ,
God making his appeal through us. We implore you on behalf of Christ,
be reconciled to God for our sake. He made him to be sin who knew no sin.
So that in him we might become the righteousness of God.
Now, what I hope you see first
is how gospel driven this is, right?
Like even our mission is centered on Jesus
reconciling work in our place on the cross.
Like so don't think they're separate like theology and study and then mission
like no, they're tied so tightly together right here.
But that good news is what compels us to live our lives every
day for him and for others to love.
Like he loved to share that message. It uses that word ambassadors to get the,
the idea across. Remember what an ambassador is,
it's an official representative of one nation to a foreign nation.
They share information, they build bridges of trust.
That's what we are here on this earth. Christians like,
remember we're citizens of heaven.
This is a temporary home and we are ambassadors to this temporary
place.
We have a message from the king to give to this nation and we have
a, a set of values of the kingdom that we are to live out here on this earth.
And so that's the idea of being an ambassador of the king.
And so don't overcomplicate this, right? When we think about mission living sin,
don't overcomplicate it. Just look at how Jesus did it cuz Jesus came from the,
the kingdom of heaven came to this earth, lived a certain way,
spoke a certain way.
Think about how Jesus did it and tried to do the things he did.
How he cared, how he spent time, how he loved how he gave,
how he served the old bracelet. What would Jesus do, right?
That actually kinda works here, right?
Like you can see this is how it plays out. What did he do? How did he do it?
Do that with your neighbors. Do that with your coworkers, with their family.
You can even do it cross-culturally right here in Edmond.
Remember the Afghan refugees that we help settle that believe in Jesus.
They've started a new church.
They're trying to reach their Afghan refugee friends, help 'em,
our Spanish brothers and sisters. They're,
they're trying to reach their community. Help 'em.
You got an ESL starting up here in a couple weeks. Go there.
There's primarily unbelievers from all over the world right there.
You can do this right here. The point is that both locally and globally,
you are to carry the ministry and message of Jesus reconciling work in your
place. Wherever you go, however you are, you don't lose the title ambassador.
You are one. But again, church,
none of this is because we have to.
None of this is because we, we,
we see God will love us only if we do these things. No,
this is because we know God already loves us.
This is a response to who he is and what he's done.
He's saved us. He chose us out of the death of sin. He said, you're mind now,
you're an ambassador of mine now and he's made us and notice that he's
made us into ministers of reconciliation.
He's made us into ambassadors.
And Craig said it really well this week in staff meeting. He said,
all we need to do now is just live out of who we already are.
That we are this. So,
so the focus is on being this rather than doing these things be
overdue. Right? See the difference there? You already are an ambassador.
You already are a minister, a me, a messenger of reconciliation.
So just be that more, just live out of it.
Instead of focusing on just doing all these things,
be the physical presence of Christ, his hands and feet.
We are the body of Christ doing what he would do. That's all it is.
Don't overcomplicate it. So that's still our mission,
church to equip one another, to love Jesus and to live sin.
That's where we're headed. But
even though nothing has changed, directionally goals,
see lives transformed in Edmond churches,
planted people sent all of these things. Nothing has changed their,
what may have changed
is how we are to go about it.
See where we live here in our area. There is a culture of,
of achievement and drive success.
All these things like there's, there's this, this undercurrent,
maybe even an over current of just pushing towards more and better and bigger.
It's sports. It's even in work, it's even in appearance. It's all over.
Which means it can seep into the church too.
See, I think that's where I got, I think I got there a little bit.
I'll share more about this next week.
But I think I got to that place of drive and achievement
rather than what you're gonna see here in a second. Now. Now let's,
let's be clear. God's commands are still God's commands, right?
There's still are what we are to do.
So we're not talking about what we are to do,
but what we need to remember is a caution in how we go about it.
The caution here is about how we actually pursue obeying
those commands.
Remember this caution as we go forward and we're gonna find one expression of it
all the way back in Psalm 1 27.
So turn left way back into the testament.
Scroll up to the middle of your Bible or so, the book of Psalms,
Psalm 1 27. You've been walking through the Psalms this summer.
We'll get to Psalm 1 27 in about eight years.
But if we're just gonna look at it for a glimpse here,
remember these psalms and prayers were meant for the worship gathering,
right? That they're meant for,
for believers to sing together as they went to worship, to pray.
And so what we're gonna read here in Psalm 1 27, these first two verses is,
is meant to be a warning to the Israelites as they worshiped, as
they went about their lives, as they participated in worship.
It was meant to be something as a, a warning to them.
We'll see it here in verses one and two of Psalm 1 27.
It says, unless the Lord builds the house, those who build it labor in vain,
unless the Lord watches over the city, the watchman stays awake in vain.
It is in vain that you rise up early and go late to rest,
eating the bread of anxious toil for he gives to his beloved
sleep. Now,
when you look at this in its context,
primarily it probably speaks of a literal building of a house in literal
protecting of a city.
But notice it was included in what we call the Psalms of ascent.
Psalm one 20 through 1 34 were intended to be used by worshipers as they went up
to the temple in Jerusalem and they would say one every step up the steps as
they went one 20 through 1 34, 1 20 sevens right in the middle of that.
So they're meant to be saying this as they're going to the temple to worship.
So it likely also applies then to the temple and to worship and to God
building his house spiritually.
Well then we think today we,
we can pull that forward to apply it to us and to the church today in similar
ways. When we think about coming to worship,
we think about God building his house.
That's why I use it here as a caution to us as we go about our mission.
Cause I heard it said one time that God can do more in five seconds than we can
do more in five years.
God can do more in five seconds than we can do on our own in five years.
Things that matter of substance. Here's what I mean. If we,
if we see this mission statement as something that we can
accomplish on our own
or we see it as something that we have to try really hard to accomplish,
then we've missed it.
If we see that as a way that we've gotta end up trying harder and and using our
resources and our smarts and our strategies,
we're gonna end up burning out or we're gonna end up giving up.
Pride is a funny sin
because pride will give God a shot for a while,
but then if he doesn't come through,
we revert back to leaning on our own strength really quickly.
But God here instead is saying in Psalm 1 27, that that,
imagine this house he's talking about is the church, big C church.
What he says in Psalm 1 27 then is, it's his job to build it.
It's his job to build the church. Jesus said the same thing, Matthew 1618.
He says, I will build my church.
Now, do we have a responsibility? Yes,
like God ordains,
that that house is built by someone moving bricks and stones and it's happening.
He doesn't just poof right it, it happens through his people.
So we have a responsibility to faithfully perform our task. Yes.
But it's ultimately his work, right? This is a spiritual work.
We can't manufacture that. It's his work. And man, listen,
that takes the pressure off, doesn't it
takes the pressure off.
Because what it does is it frees us up to merely be faithful,
to merely be obedient,
to be good stewards and to trust him for the fruit that he wants to produce.
Listen, we've gotta be really careful to not trust our resources,
to not trust our talents, our size, our influence,
our history,
whatever it is to trust that stuff instead of trusting God to build his church.
Because this is what the end of Ephesians three says,
that he is able to do far more abundantly than all that we ask or think
according to the power at work within us.
To him be the glory in the church and in Christ Jesus throughout all
generations, forever and ever. Amen. Right?
He can do way more than we can try to figure out on our own.
But here's what that means. That means we better pray then, right?
That means when we talk about desperate dependence being one of our church's
values, how does that really show up here?
Does it like, does that desperate depend? Is asking God to work?
Does that really show up? I mean, how many prayer meetings are really going on?
Like if we say, God, we are desperate for you to move,
but we're not gonna ask you, we're not gonna depend on you in any other way.
How is that matching?
How many of us are truly crying out to the Lord to do what only he can take the
credit for? Or do we just think this thing's gonna work,
this thing's gonna manufacture itself.
It's gonna happen because we have all these people,
we have all these staff members. We got all this money,
we got this building like we, it's gonna happen.
So we don't need to ask God for what? Where did that come from?
If these three months changed me in any way, it was in this area
like that, that we need to slow down more
and just let God be God Instead of us trying to figure
it out. Just let him do it. Cuz if he,
he doesn't build it, it's worthless. Whatever we build.
Speaking of changes, I hadn't been in this part of our building since April,
so you can imagine when I walked in here,
it was like Franc from Father of the Blind. Hello. You know,
like big changes around here. So
here's, here's what I say that if you weren't here last Sunday, you missed out.
And we weren't here last Sunday morning,
but we came last Sunday afternoon because when this building was built 20 years
ago, before they put anything down on the floors, it was just bare concrete.
They had the church come in and they had everyone write scripture and prayers
over this floor in Sharpies,
just asking God to do something. Well,
last week when we had the carpet ripped out,
before we put the new carpet back in,
it was so encouraging to walk around and see faint
remnants. Sometimes you could read it, sometimes you couldn't.
But just scripture and prayer that people 20 years ago,
years ago had prayed over this building saying, God, we need you to move here.
If you don't move, we're we're just having a good time together.
It's not worth it. It's not worth anything. And so you walked around,
you could see right underneath the, the feet that you have right now,
like right there, people were writing scripture and prayers,
and I was overwhelmed as I thought about how we are standing here on the
shoulders of so many who've come and given and sacrificed and prayed and asked
God to work. This is not because we're awesome.
It's because God for so many years has worked through this. And
then I,
I saw fresh sharpies all over here and all over there that some of you came
back Sunday and wrote prayers and scriptures of fresh as you were praying for us
today, but also for those coming 20 years from now. And you're saying, God,
we need you to do something here. We need you to work.
That's all because of this. Psalm 1 27.
We need God to do what only he can do.
We can't come up with a good enough strategy to change someone's life.
We've got to remember that all of this is God's work, God's way.
This is God's church, God's way. This is God's mission, God's way.
This is all who we are as historically, Henderson Hills.
It's God's deal. We're gonna be that way going forward as well.
And so Psalm 1 27 doesn't mean stop working, stop giving,
stop building, stop guarding. It doesn't mean any of that.
It just means we recognize our limitations as we do those things.
I'm not a good enough preacher to save anyone
to save the world. We're not good enough. Kids ministry, student ministry.
We're not good enough musically to do anything to change someone's life.
It has to be only God working through his means and his gospel
to build his church.
But I also think it applies to us individually.
When you take stock of your day-to-day life,
how much of it looks like you forcing things through?
You're trying to make things happen again,
scripture values hard work.
So we're not abdicated from our responsibilities in life.
But how are you trusting yourself?
How are you trusting your money, your power, your position, your whatever?
How does Psalm 1 27 show up in your life? Because listen,
you might be building your life on the shifting sands of what you
bring to the table yourself, your intellect,
your resources, your whatever,
instead of placing your whole life in his hands
and being faithful, being good steward, but just laying it in his hands.
But, but what it looks like in your life right now is that you're,
you're rising early. You're going to bed late.
You're working your fingers to the bone in worry and anxiety.
That's what it looks like for you right now.
What this says to us instead is just rest in him as his beloved.
Rest in him, as his beloved. It's what our students learned all week that,
that unless we abide in the vine of Christ,
then us as branches,
we're not gonna produce the fruit that God intends for us to produce.
We're disconnected branches trying to squeeze fruit out. It doesn't work.
It's gotta stay connected. As
long as we continue to depend on ourselves in our lives,
we are resigned to eating the bread of anxious toil.
Psalm 1 27 says,
and all of our work notice three times it says in those two verses,
we'll be in vain, fruitless, worthless.
You can build a life and it's worthless.
But when we're resting, when we're resting,
trusting we can afford to relax because God never does.
We can sleep because God's always active.
We don't have to create life because God is life.
Does that not bring utter humility before him?
Should that not foster some,
some humility that the fruit of our work is contingent on whether he's doing it
or not. Like don't forget that as you go about life,
what this means is that we can be good stewards. We can, we can. Matthew Levin,
his yoke is easy. His his burden is life.
We can just walk through life faithfully, stewarding it, being generous,
being sacrificial, just a good steward,
and trust him completely with the results.
It might not look like everybody else around you. Doesn't matter.
It's what God wants.